how are you Patrick although there is
ingredients so I am doing fine other
than yourself who is the best cornerback
in this league
what do you have for me yeah hey Asha
nice question oh um why cuz it's Richard
Sherman that one no it's just because
you always hit all what about this guy
what about that guy you know but I den
do down I was definitely you know I mean
this is can are going to be number one
as well you know so he's definitely you
know a guy that you know that that's
always been kidding it can you always
talk about the best thing again
receiving MRIs so have you end up good
with have you and the rest of the
Cardinals taken notice of the stories
about the so called dissension in the
Seahawks locker room Patrick no not
really
there's you know me personally I don't
really focus you know protected to too
much what goes on in the media I kind of
didn't dab in there every once in a
while but I haven't heard anything as of
late you know sense of sense you know
the whole April you know debacle came
out or whatever so other than that I
hadn't really heard anything Patrick
Peterson here on the Rich Eisen show of
do you read Bruce Arians book three
coaches book no I did not I don't even
have a copy yet wait a minute not come
on now seriously he's not I don't even
have a copy of it's not even stack so
I'm I'm sure I'm sure get one I'm sorry
okay well it seems like he actually
wrote it Patrick seems like he actually
you know yeah that's what that's what I
heard that's what I heard you know I've
been here Pat talked about it you know
on social media um saying it's a you
know it's a great read so I mean
eventually once I get my once I get my
book out definitely look into it as well
what do you mean you've got a book
coming out
no into it when I get coach book oh I
thought that you said once you get your
book I see what you're saying
I thought Patrick period there's a new
no not yet not yet not yes they got a
lot to write what what what is the title
of your memoir going to be Patrick what
do you think Oh what do you got
probably
I don't know shutting down a spot
without shut down shut up obviously I
probably push em just be quiet like that
that's the name of the book is yeah
because I'm always we got us you know
that that that you know they don't get
much much talk about my place or us I
would be just like she's always in the
background all we just sleep always
chill I see or you just you're you have
everything inside or you shut everybody
up with your pleasure that's what I'm
saying that too you know like Dion's
Dion's probably but I would tell them
hold it up that would be his thing
because you know you holds it up as you
know exact I hold it up there you got it
that's what he's always screaming at
people whenever I watch him watch him to
try to return one and then you do Oh duh
that's what he's holding up as what he
screams when you just when you get
around to the 35 Patrick with 35 more to
go that's what he wanted to holding it
up and high-steppin already know so in
one of the things about Bruce Arians
book to that I love how he lays bare is
his philosophy and he's really the only
coach I know of there may be others
where he openly talks Super Bowl with
the team and I'm wondering if here can
you look around and you think that this
could be the last rodeo for Carson and
Larry Fitzgerald if not your coach as
well if you feel the window of
opportunities right now oh definitely I
mean honestly throw the window of
opportunity as always right now you know
we're a team that you know that's always
you know then you know like fighting for
your respect and fighting for to get
into the playoffs and fight for one of
those teams that's nationally talked
about so at the end of the day the
window is always you know short force
and we definitely always want to win now
that's a philosophy right around here
like expect coaches always talking about
you know Super Bowl because at the end
of the day at the end of the day that's
the ultimate goal and I will working
we're definitely working towards that
goal and hopefully you know Louis will
enough we're able to stay healthy we
have the talent to do it you know we
just always suffer you know late late
season injuries
the guys can't come back or where it's
really you know taking a toll on our
dicas on authors wherever the injury may
occur so but um we definitely think we
have what it takes but at the end of the
day to help his team when they get
Israel well I mean you've got um I think
you're referring to tyre in Matthews
injury that occurred at a very
unfortunate time and then Carson Palmer
in the same game - am i if I'm not
mistaken in Philadelphia are you guys
went down right there which is again
just another point about how things you
need to strike while the iron's hot
how's David Johnson looking Patrick when
David's looking like David anyway even
better you know you know it was never
you know question if he was going to
come back and be healthy and do other
things that he once did um I think that
injury it was something very very minor
kill him you know he's looking very good
good kept you know I look forward to
watching clay Rumble again this year and
you had at Ramon Williams so you got del
Del Zotto
Louisiana Tech guy coming in to join the
LSU it so it's it's sort of like a whole
Bayou secondary that seems to be yeah
yeah yeah I just saw that so you know
aside yet another sub you got added in
the room and hopefully can kind of help
couples you know not only on the
football field also you know helping
these young guys um get compared because
I will see he's here for one year we can
use them but also here's another brain
that means John gasket Patrick Peterson
joining me here for a couple more
minutes on the Rich Eisen show what'd
you think of Odell Beckham saying that
NFL players need to be paid like NBA
players and he believes one day he will
be the highest-paid in the entire league
what'd you think of that
um vote about what first of all I mean
he he doesn't have the opportunity to be
you know the hottest cape you know
League lot you know that you know deal
especially on he's definitely a guy that
you know if I had to spend my last
hundred dollars to watch a game or watch
but you know a guy person he's
definitely it will be not top three um
but getting pay like NBA players I don't
think it would happen because uh first
of all there's too many guys and
obviously we I you know I do think
the taking you know I you know make the
contract a little bit more guarantee
make the contract fully guarantee you
know things like that's where you can
have embedded causes to where if you get
traded to a team maybe the king can
still you know who or you just give all
that Jim accounted for that previous
contract maybe things like that but for
us you know getting paid like then be a
guys I don't think that happened
how's Chandler Jones crawling about his
brother hearing about it you know you
know he's always pretty smooth you know
but we all knew that that uh John Jones
was one of the sure that guy so it was
almost like us you see no brainer you
say this there were no Cormier fans in
the locker room not Arizona not one not
war and I'll be disrespected that'd be
really how's the culture golf game going
before I let you go I'm sorry I played
horrible in Tahoe but as soon as I get
back home I played lights out yeah I
don't I don't know what it is about you
know that that tiger isn't you know the
year before I played a little brother
okay
please xx last year I believe I place
like fifty ninth or something like that
just so complete five steps backwards
huh but you know when I come when I come
back home I play well and um you know at
the end of the day golfers go you know
it's just just trying to find a way to
keep getting better and you know just
something I also just keeps me real
mellowed out and just chilled and you
know making about other ventures and you
know thanks you know a lot of how to get
better how to good how to get up how to
be a better a better father being
patient and things like that there's
those just some small things I love
about the game really you you you think
golf will help you become more patient
with how old your kids oh yeah because
at the end of the day you know sometimes
when you hit that you're off is not
going to go your way all the time you
have to find a way how to fight you know
either you know on a wait how to fight
out of trouble get out of trouble I'm
sorry you know you have to you know if
you having a bad partner you have to
find a way to pull it together and get
it together on the background you know
Golf is all about patience and it
definitely helps me focus on my patience
and like I said they also helps me
outside
football outside of golfing real-life
situation as well no no my wife always
has no problem when I when I want to go
play golf because she knows what a great
break it is for me are you saying that
the next time that I get short with my
children on patience I should turn to my
wife and say you know what I need to
play some more golf you think that will
work
yeah is that about it where's me
Patrick Peterson told me I need to play
more golf makes me a better dad I love
that I like to take that home on how
portable that is hold it up that might
be that a that might be something to
mush
[Laughter]
Patrick love chat with you say hi to
everybody over there for me okay and
we'll chat down the line
all right state their it's the one and
only Patrick Peterson
so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like some of
that get some more of that on the Rich
Eisen show lap follow all the
information you see right here on the
Rich Eisen show